let's say you're a sight a nyaka puss
and you don't care for the burgundy red
color of your skin how about something
in a dose a pale pink no problem
done you just expand or shrink the
millions of pigment cells or
chromatophores in your skin to instantly
change color you can also use tiny
muscles in your skin to change its
texture now a kind of snakeskin print
might be just the thing for a
fashionable octopus trying to blend in
with a smart set fashionable and low-key
off the radar of any hungry sharks
passing by and nobody here just another
rock formation once that danger is
passed
it's time for prey to become predator
here's some remarkable close-up footage
of a sight any octopus going hunting
what are you looking for crustaceans and
mollusks that are as good at hiding as
you are
well almost here's a sigh any aside view
of a reef flat that seems like nothing
but a couple of billion hidey-holes
of course that's where your amazing
tentacles come in handy you literally
feel your way across the cracks and
crevices your suckers are so sensitive
you can actually use them to taste what
you touch aha you sense a meal that
means it's time to unfurl yourself like
an exterminators tent engulfing a
termite filled house
your prey is trapped your grip is sure
your arm tips go to work
flushing out bits of food and
disappearing them into your maw until
recently no one knew what was happening
underneath your web don't ask us how but
we're going to reveal your dining habits
senior say Nia here's what's going on
this crab gets thrust into what's called
your beak your bite has a little toxin
just enough to seal the crabs doom now
that we know what's going on under that
web we don't ever need to see that again
do we